the deputy sheriff assigned to protect
Marjory Stoneman Douglas high school is
out of a job this morning accused of
failing to do his duty during last
week's massacre the Broward County
Sheriff says deputy Scott Peterson
should have quote killed the killer
instead he never went inside the school
building during the gun fire that left
17 people dead
the sheriff's angry news conference
followed yesterday's funeral for Aaron
Feist the football coach and security
guard who ran toward danger to protect
students Manuel Bojorquez is outside
Stoneman Douglas high in parkland
Florida where there are other questions
about the deputy's work man well good
morning good morning deputy Scott
Peterson had been assigned to Stoneman
Douglas high school for at least the
last eight years according to Sheriff
Department records twice before the
shooting he received information about
disturbing behavior involving the
suspect Nicolas Nicolas Cruz but
officials say his suspension and
resignation are a result of what
happened during the shooting devastated
sick to my stomach Broward County
Sheriff Scott Israel said Thursday as a
shooting unfolded inside Stoneman
Douglas High School deputy Scott
Peterson stayed outside when we in law
enforcement arrived at an active shooter
we go in and address the target and
that's what should have been done police
say suspect Nicolas Cruz entered the
high school's building 12 from the east
side where he shot into four classrooms
he then took the stairs to the second
floor on the west side of the building
and allegedly shot a victim in another
classroom he left behind his ar-15 in
the third floor East stairwell
according to police during the shooting
deputy Peterson stayed outside of
building 12 on the west side for about
four minutes the shooting lasted about
six I'm Scott
according to Broward County Sheriff
records in February 2016 information was
allegedly forwarded to Peterson that
Cruz planned to shoot up the school it's
unclear what was done with the
information since 2008 the Broward
Sheriff's Office was involved in 23 type
calls involving the killer in some way
shape or form or his brother
in a November nine one one call obtained
by Fox affiliate WFL X a family friend
claims cruz pointed a shotgun at her
pissed
one day after speaking at the White
House Andrew Pollock hosted around 200
people at his home in Coral Springs
Florida to remember his daughter meadow
Pollock who was killed in the shooting
her friends expressed anger and
frustration at the news about deputy
Peterson the Broward County Sheriff's
Office says two other deputies are also
under review for how they handled
information about the suspect Nicholas
Cruz before the shooting we reached out
to deputy Scott Peterson for comment but
have not heard back
the sheriff says even though that deputy
has resigned the investigation into his
actions will continue